from self-driving cars to personalized
virtual assistants artificial
intelligence is changing the game with
its mind-boggling ability to analyze
data and make decisions it's not
transforming Industries it's shaping a
future where the extraordinary is
becoming the everyday AI tools have a
lot to offer from making tasks easier to
improving how we interact with
technology as we approach 2024 there are
some exciting AI tools available to help
both businesses and individuals in this
video we'll talk about the top 10 AI
tools for 2024 each of these tools has
its own unique abilities and ways it can
be used
so whether you want to automate small
tasks make better decisions or get more
insights from data these tools can help
you do just that and open up new
possibilities in artificial intelligence
hello everyone and you are already
watching simply before we start with the
top 10 AI tools for 2024 remember to
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily
already hit the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from Simply AI is
revolutionizing the world at an
unprecedented Pace it's clear that this
technology is not going down in the near
future so if you want to stay ahead in
this steep competition curve in today's
world then simply learns postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with the Purdue University
is your go to option this program helps
you learn in-demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and many you will receive a
prestigious certificate and ask me
anything sessions by IBM with over three
cap stunts in different domains using
real data sets you will gain practical
experience master classes by Purity
faculty and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education admission to this postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning
requires a bachelor's degree with an
average of 50 or higher marks basic
understanding of programming Concepts
and Mathematics candidate with two plus
years of experience are preferred so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities check out
the link mentioned in the description
box below for more details let's start
with the top 10 AI tools for 2024. at
number 10 we have click up click up is a
versatile project management tool that
can be used for various tasks from
managing a team to tracking personal
goals it offers over 100 role-based AI
prompts enabling more efficient task
management with features like
reprompting for improved results
translation capabilities for 12
languages and thread summaries for
better comment tracking it caters to
diverse project needs while clickups
Mobile support for all features is still
under development it remains a valuable
tool for boosting productivity
there is a free trial available and for
paid workspace access it costs seven
dollars per member per month with
various pricing plans to choose from so
give click up a try to streamline your
work processes
at number nine we have the Jasper AI
Jasper is great for better AI writing
it's good for blogs and scripts you can
make detailed outlines in your voice and
customized tones but long writing can be
tough with Jasper Ai and the trial is
also Limited
prices of 49 dollars per month for the
Creator plan and 125 dollar per month
for the team's plan and custom pricing
for businesses moving on to number eight
we have tab nine tab nine an AI powered
coding assistant enhances coding
efficiency by interpreting natural
language comments and suggesting
relevant code it's compatible with
various code editors and supports
multiple programming languages
key features include Auto completion
natural language to code transformation
and customization to fit your coding
style the free plan offers basic
functionality while the Pro Plan at 12
per month per user unlocks Advanced
features
overall tab 9 is a valuable tool for
developers seeking coding assistance and
productivity enhancement
at number 7 we have the blue willow blue
Willows Air Generation tool swiftly
creates brand logos marketing materials
and Graphics based on text inputs
delivering better results with detailed
descriptions operating through Discord
it offers features like result
refinement direct image saving and
Artistic Styles pricing options ranges
from free to villover at five dollar per
month Blue Angel at ten dollar per month
and Sapphire at 20 dollar per month so
if you also want to create your own
artificial intelligence tool and gain
more knowledge about Ai and want to
become an artificial intelligence
engineer then you can accelerate your
career with this master's program in
artificial intelligence by simply learn
in collaboration with the IBM Masters in
AI include industry relevant courses
such as data science with python machine
learning deep learning NLP and chat GPT
and also features hackathons and ask me
anything sessions hosted by IBM so get
job ready in the AI domain with Capstone
projects practical labs live sessions
and Hands-On projects participants in
this Masters in artificial intelligence
course should know Python Programming
Concepts and basic statistical knowledge
to understand the essential machine
learning and AI Concepts and candidates
with one plus year of experience are
preferred so what are you waiting for
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
moving on to number six we have
Synthesia Synthesia is a robust AI tool
that swiftly transforms plain text into
engaging web browser videos this
user-friendly content creation tool
enables professional quality video
production for sales marketing and more
with life like AI avatars and narration
supporting 120 languages and encouraging
team collaboration it offers features
like text to video conversion
multilingual voiceovers and
customizations however video and caption
editing may be time consuming and scene
limits worry by pricing plan
Synthesia provides a 30 per month
personal plan for individuals and
customizable Enterprise plans for teams
streamlining AI driven content creation
at number five we have pictori pictori
ai offers an AI driven video creation
tool that simplifies turning written
content into engaging videos it
leverages features like stock footage
music and voice overs to convert blog
posts into visual content with these
while some voiceovers may sound robotic
pictory AI is available for a free trial
and offers standard premium and teams
plan priced at
19.39.99 respectively making video
creation accessible with AI though
voiceovers and language support me worry
moving on to number four we have
mid-journey mid journey is an AI powered
image generation tool designed for
Creative individuals it allows users to
describe their vision and mid Journeys
Discord bot transform these text prompts
into visually compelling Graphics
suitable for web designs or social media
campaigns the tool offers a
user-friendly interface and has improved
the quality of web Graphics it also
benefits from an active Discord
Community however it's important to note
that while the prompting tool can
upscale images it may alter the original
design and for newcomers to Discord
using my journey may be initially
confusing my journey offers a free trial
and pricing plans including basic for 10
per month standard for 30 dollar per
month and Pro Plan for sixty dollars per
month
time for the top three artificial
intelligence tools for 2024. at number
three we have right Sonic right Sonic
creates SEO optimized content using open
AIS GPT 4 model it offers enhanced
content generation with paid plans
Twitter and Linkedin integration voice
command and plagiarism detection
however the free trial is limited to one
user and has word count restrictions
right Sonic uses a credit based system
so plan ahead pricing starts at 12.67
dollars per month for the Pro Plan and
custom pricing is available for the
Enterprise plan explore write Sonics
content creation capabilities with the
free trial
at number two we have the GitHub
co-pilot GitHub copilot seamlessly
integrate into your code editor
leveraging openai codecs for
comprehensive code generation it
supports various languages like python
JavaScript typescript go and C plus plus
this AI power tool facilitates pair
programming with contextual Solutions it
offers robust integration with popular
coding environments however be prepared
for a learning curve and potentially
slower coding in real time GitHub
copilot is available for individuals at
10 per month and for Enterprises at 19
per user per month discover its coding
efficiency today
and finally at number one we have the
undefeated chair GPT chargpt stands out
as the top AI tool known for its ease of
use and versatility it can engage in
conversations
explain complex Concepts Aid in research
and generate diverse content including
code
while its Simplicity and multilingual
capabilities makes it accessible to all
it may occasionally provide generic
responses and lack of human level
creativity
users can opt for a free version or the
plus plan priced at twenty dollars per
month
chat Deputy offers a user-friendly
experience with minor quirks in
responses and creativity so explore its
capabilities today
as we look ahead more advanced AI tools
are on the horizon these tools will help
individuals and businesses streamline
processes boost productivity and gain
faster insights from data the future of
AI is exciting and these 10 discus tools
are already valuable for improving
efficiency in personal and professional
life
and with that we have reached the end of
this session on the top 10 AI tools for
2024. before we end this video let's
take a minute to hear it out from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers
you need to keep updating your skills
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning
if you guys need any assistance
regarding this video please let us know
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible
so until next time thank you and keep
learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you